HE'S DISMANTLING THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
JOHN.
>> John: RICH EDSON AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
THANKS SO MUCH.
THERE'S PLENTY OF DAYLIGHT
BETWEEN THE MAIN CANDIDATES
RUNNING FOR MEXICO'S PRESIDENCY
IN THE SUMMER'S ELECTION.
NOT WHEN IT COMES TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
OUR NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
WILLIAM LA JEUNESSE TELLS US
FROM LOS ANGELES THE AMERICAN
LEADER IS ONE THING MOST
MEXICANS CAN SURELY AGREE ON.
>> THE RACE FOR MEXICO'S NEXT
PRESIDENT FEATURES THREE VERY
DIFFERENT CANDIDATES, THE RULING
PARTY, THE REFORMER AND X
RADICAL.
THE BERNIE SANDERS OF MEXICO.
KNOWN FOR HIS FIREBRAND STYLE.
HIS INITIALS, OBRADOR PLACED
SECRETARY IN THE LAST TWO
ELECTIONS BUT REFUSED TO
CONCEDE.
HE PROMISES TO BREAK UP
MONOPOLIES AND USE THE
UNITED NATIONS TO STOP THE
BORDER WALL.
>> THEY WANT SOMEBODY WHO WILL
STAND UP AND REPRESENT MEXICO
MORE INDEPENDENTLY.
HIS MAIN CHALLENGER IS RICARDO
ANAYA.
HE IS RUNNING WITH SUPPORT FROM
THE LEFT AND RIGHT.
HE SUPPORTS A UNIVERSAL BASIC
INCOME PAID FOR BY ELIMINATING
WELFARE.
HE WOULD LEAD MEXICO'S FIRST
COALITION GOVERNMENT.
>> I THINK THERE'S AN APPETITE
IN MEXICO FOR GOING FOR NEW
PEOPLE.
>> FROM THE ESTABLISHMENT COMES
WAS A ANTONIO MEADE.
HE IS EXPERIENCED BUT CARRIES
THE BURDEN OF THE INSTITUTIONAL
REVOLUTIONARY PARTY.
>> HE IS NOT A GAME-CHANGER IN
BEING ABLE TO REPRESENT A NEW
CURRENT INSIDE THE PRI.
>> ACCORDING TO THE LATEST POLL,
OBRADOR.
HE IS THE FAVORITE.
>> HE ISN'T HAMPERED BY THEIR